what's up guys this is christian from
long island new york checking in for the
debate club i got the debate club
y'all gonna do this i gotta debate
call an attorney bro that's the advice
sorry the debate club i got the debate
club for y'all y'all gon
y'all gonna do this debate i wanna see
which side you're on come on
who would you choose harry and megan
or the institution we heard what's
happening with them over there in the uk
i mean one side then people different
they different so i want to know your
opinion who y'all got harry and megan
batman or that game that they call the
institution
let me know and by the way i love all
y'all in there y'all make my day every
time
y'all drop at 12 a.m on fridays new york
time
i'm watching so gang game buzz buzz take
care y'all
feliz papa ewa from the empire state
dude pete rose i love the first of all i
love the pete rose is that elton john is
that an elton john
puzzle behind him is that elton john i
don't think so dude that's elton john on
a horse
i think probably sitting at a piano if
elton john's on anything it's a man
okay if that horse has a male first name
dude john on dave yeah
yeah first of all i am shocked by this i
thought this guy's questioning me about
frankie edgar i had no
idea that this guy's question was gonna
land where it did the royal family did
you see any of that
i didn't see the interview but i saw the
cliff notes and we're only getting one
side of it
right what i'm saying right we're only
getting what yeah the
i mean yeah it's like the stale oprah
kind of sound bitey
yeah i want to see queen elizabeth on a
hot mic start talking about it
also that family's how old hundreds of
years
of yeah they're gonna be a tad racist
man well i don't think it'd be a tad
racist they might just kind of like
being white i mean first of all we don't
even know
they didn't they love them getting
married didn't they want them living i
mean no
they didn't markle and them chose to
leave man marco's a kind of thotty
she's thought he yeah yeah around l.a
she started but
well look i'm sorry your highness i
don't know about thotty but i think if
you move
to you don't move to la because you're
trying to have a peaceful life with your
husband
montecito that's right dude here's
montecito as a place where rich people
hide
that's where ellen degeneres is at
that's where george clooney's at
that's 20 million up son for chris oh
you can't even yeah dude i've driven up
there you know it's eleven dollars to
drive through the neighborhood up there
yeah that's where it should be might
even joke google how much does it cost
to drive through a pebble beach
neighborhood
yeah you ever been out yeah you've been
up there yeah i just told you i've been
up there i drove through it i know i
thought it was a lie
huh he thinks i lied [ __ ] hashtag
ufc 257.
i'm going to get all those photoshops
holy [ __ ]
10 see you live it's 10.50
yeah hashtag ufc 275
[Laughter]
uh but isn't that crazy to dr imagine if
it costs to just
drive through your neighborhood every
time you want to get in your
neighborhood it's ten dollars and of
course queen of
elizabeth is pissed because you're
supposed to live in that [ __ ] castle
what's wrong with the dopey ass castle
then you just take all your [ __ ] get out
and move to la she's like what the [ __ ]
is going on here
yeah and she came and got harry and then
she jetted out
you know now harry going bad on all the
family
i hear i i i predict this i think that
i i don't know if they stay together i
don't know but i don't still who really
knows
that's what i'm saying i we just got one
side of the story right now
i just feel like they could have like i
would have loved her seen her start some
big acting thing over in the uk
and make some really cool stuff over
there and kind of champion what's going
on over there
were they that racist that she felt it
didn't sound like there was that racist
they said hey the baby might have a
little collar
look dog they said that baby might come
out shea darker than we're used to
around this cast
they're like we're [ __ ] out of here
we're going to la like all right we're
just wondering
yeah yeah so i think look i think
sometimes you got to darken up the baby
dude you know what i'm saying yeah
tan on them yeah if you've been to
detroit sometimes you got to darken up
the baby
now you know who's taking heat right now
probably going to lose his job at pier
is piers morgan who i love
but he went hard on uh megan and uh
harry there well the biggest thing is
just against tradition it's like
you know the media constantly uses like
racism
accusations of racism to attack
tradition you know harry and
uh maggle or whatever got
megan sorry got uh they got seven
million dollars to do their podcast
oh [ __ ] they have a podcast
yeah so look let's just modify they're
selling look they're selling
they're selling something they're
selling something that's the thing
they're selling you got to look at them
you can't look at them as like
human beings that are trying to share
real information you got to look at them
there's an agenda yeah there's an agenda
with all this there's a sales people
so you're not talking you're not at uh
you're not at a place where you're
talking to somebody you're out of barnes
and noble
so if you want to leave with any
information you're paying for and then
she said she had mental issues she was
suicidal because they were so mean to
her and she went to someone in the
castle and like [ __ ]
we're 700 years old you go to
betterhelp.com
cat yeah and also i thought you
harry is part of like is the head of
like is on the board of like 15 mental
health organizations [ __ ] yeah i
asked him for help yeah
talk to your husband doug look i now i
understand if you get tired of the
ballrooms and people
fake sword fighting and [ __ ] over the
tradition that [ __ ] sounds lit
eating chicken with your hands drinking
from those big [ __ ] vats bro
game of thrones it's the original nelk
boys i think she should have just stuck
with it and
and lived it out but maybe she just got
tired of it
you know um she always wanted to be a
uh actress but also those castles seem
pretty chilly
you know like there's the breeze all
night man the open windows stone walls
there's guards everywhere all the
[ __ ] donuts yeah the guys
shooting people walking up to the castle
sounds fun it sounds dope
i've been immediate medieval times i
can't get enough
i think it's probably like being trapped
at medieval times yeah
you can boss people around off with
their heads be sick
yeah they said they paid 25 million to
do the podcast and seven and nine
million to do that interview with oprah
wow so 25 million for the spotify
podcast
right damn spotify pan so let's just
like i don't know but also who the [ __ ]
is those two but i like it look i like i
don't think the baby has anything to do
to do with it
i think i think someone raised the
question was like hey man
that kid can be like a shade of brown or
we just we just want to know
yeah that's right someone threw right
through that out there and she got all
pissed off
yeah like do we want the baby crib to
have like
you know do we want it to have bass in
the [ __ ] you know like do we want
speakers in the corner of it is it weird
if i get a pair of jordans for his first
birthday or
just trying to figure [ __ ] out here man
i think you got to plan ahead
you know i think yeah do we want that
candy paint on the side of the crib like
what kind of thing are we planning ahead
for
i think they could have made an awesome
thing over there by making this exciting
for england
and done like fresh prince of bel-air
type of thing you know wouldn't that
have been awesome
you know with everybody but now it's
like jeffrey the butler is like the
[ __ ] it's his house that they're
living at
because he's originally from the uk
joffrey yeah then they're fighting with
swords
it's on a ig story every morning harry
just killing dudes
but he really [ __ ] up girl now you're
montecito you got your next door
neighbors ellen is probably the biggest
[ __ ] you've ever met
like that's what you get well now you're
just living
in a life that's really i don't know
probably pretty dope
22 million dollar crib montecito dope
yeah but you're also very lonely
and now you don't get to see all these
cool battles you don't get to eat
chicken all the time with your hands
yeah
turkey leg yeah turkey leg yeah you
don't get to whisper to somebody in the
hallway yeah
yeah they're coming tonight yeah yeah
and the guy's like who yeah the british
are coming
[ __ ] we are the british i would like to
see
uh you know meghan markle's go
uh full black go [ __ ] full black boo
boo
okay move to [ __ ] in youngstown
okay buy a house in detroit move to
kingston jamaica
you know what i'm saying do a mixtape
with uh sean the guy that shows somebody
with the
yeah do a [ __ ] mixtape you know what
i'm saying like if you flirt with black
culture then [ __ ] flirt with it baby
girl yeah one
girl oh we're struggling you know
they're saying the baby's black the baby
you know
they're saying the baby has a little
tenuchi [ __ ] tattoo on his back
[ __ ] go do some black [ __ ] with the
baby okay
go to youngstown ohio go to [ __ ]
detroit go to [ __ ]
hampton roads boo boo go to norfolk all
right
instead you living out in this [ __ ]
safe ass montecito
the safest yeah well i bet maybe arthur
ash's kids are your only [ __ ]
neighbors
that have any color so let's be honest
if you're gonna play color play color
booboo
all right but don't [ __ ] play white
and just don't don't hide and go seeking
the white [ __ ]
and just flirt out with the black [ __ ]
when you need money gang
you also knew what you signed up for you
knew what you signed up for going that
castle
yeah it's a castle [ __ ]
i know queen elizabeth is 5 000 years
old
i know but then i wonder here's what i
wonder does harry have any clout in this
whole deal or is he just kind of being
drug alone now he's a little side piece
she's like this what we're going to do
and do oprah we get seven mil son we're
gonna buy a 22 million dollar house
montecito
and then [ __ ] that castle oh yeah i want
you to throw all your family under the
bus and he's all okay
and it's one of those buses too because
it's for tours yeah
yeah it's red yeah you
no he does
[Laughter]
damn boy he's hook he's in bro
she might be a bad [ __ ] in the sack so
he's like [ __ ] but how bad can you be
we can't get all right match it up in
the castle man she might be yelling it
might be
wild dog yeah go down that dungeon and
[ __ ]
yeah you know they got a dungeon oh yeah
come on
god there's axes with double axes yeah
yeah bring them a picture of that dog
you can you can dress like those guys
that used to decapitate people with the
black mask
and [ __ ] get a ball in your mouth
dude
ball in your mouth that's what they did
and that's something i kicked out of the
house
you want some other [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
you better [ __ ]
look at that you get to have that yeah
you can play with all that [ __ ]
and it just shows up you're not paying
for it they got more money you know they
think queen elizabeth is the richest
person on earth
yeah they say she runs you talk to sam
tripoli he thinks she runs the entire
world
you play with axes and [ __ ] who's
complaining now
granted i'll probably move out too
that's from grayskull
yeah they beat grayskull didn't they
british dude they probably
got a baby dragon on that [ __ ] too yeah
dragons oh dude dragons and hoes harry
oh dude that's right what are we doing
bro bro imagine trying to [ __ ]
by a sleeping dragon playing don't wake
the dragon with your wife
that'd be hot and now you're up here in
montecito eating [ __ ] fancy lobster
rolls and
checking your instagram every two
minutes to make sure your life's okay
y'all [ __ ] sold out i can show you
the music isn't too loud because ellen's
gonna yell at you through the window
but that's your life bubba that's what
you signed up for i just would have
liked to seen them stay in the pocket
and change the game yeah fight it out
dude yeah and they cool
make cool moves make cool yeah we're
going to get around get around london on
a [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
yeah we got the little dark british
right here bro we got that first [ __ ]
dark british
and chain be in the pocket and change up
inspire people
instead now you out here [ __ ] playing
games and selling your [ __ ]
yep yeah you could have rick ross at the
castle doing a concert
yeah the british are coming
the british are coming oh oh
oh i can't breathe they got wing stop
[ __ ] sponsoring the thing
yeah the lemon pepper yeah and the
dragons feeding on them too you know how
lit that instagram would be
a little small arm big tail dragon
[ __ ] teriyaki that dry baby come on
god damn you guys [ __ ] up you [ __ ]
up
yeah i enjoy paying the money for the
[Music]
neighborhood
[Music]
is